well you're not nice and you know what
no exclusive bye-bye
oh no now wait sir please don't kick me
out well look at that you don't want to
leave see you got to be nice to me if
you want access that's the way things
work around here
you're a crook and you're a liar your
first year is a disaster you like women
really young yet you make me age faster
you're like a powerful narcotic but our
relationship is sin big ain't it the
truth
the news was a
when you unwrap your presents on
December 25th you remember who's
for those girls we
each other
[Music]
each other like each other
I need you to scream breaking news and I
eat you for big ad revenues we both yell
out by name sake News ABC let me see
Jesus how many NBC's are there I don't
know like 50 you know I'm Jewish right
so hard
[Music]
I love you
[Applause]
you
[Music]